[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 84 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mendel hey Mark how are
you doing I am very well how are you
doing
Brigid enjoying an amazing weather here
in New York yeah thank you come you are
in San Francisco I am in San Francisco
yes
and very excited about today's episode
we're gonna be talking about so we had
at the episode of big data on data sets
last week yep and one of the cool things
that you can do with data sets is you
could organize things like competitions
right and that's what Carol does and we
have when they can software engineer
from cargo that's gonna tell us
everything about it which is very
exciting
yeah they do some really awesome big
data competition so I'm super glad to
have them on so we can talk of all about
them yeah and they do have also some
awesome awesome data sets that are
available for competitions but also to
anyone to play with so really really
cool and then at the end we'll have a
question about I think it was last week
of the week before we mentioned headless
kubernetes services and we said that if
you don't know what they mean you should
go read that article that we link to so
today we have a question above them
partly it's about kubernetes in G RPC
and services and stuffs but that will be
at the end of the episode yep before we
start we have the cool things of the
week
and we have a bunch of them today yeah
one of them is kind of related to one
episode of a long long time ago episode
72 which is like three months ago
all righty or something like that crazy
on the CRA customer reliability
engineering we had looked stone that
came to tell us about it well they wrote
an article which is really cool it's how
sre find the land mines in a service CRE
life lessons which is basically what
we're talking about if you become a
customer of CRE or a multi customer it's
almost like a partner with Siri there's
going to be some analysis of what you're
doing your services what are the things
that might cause problems and that's
exactly what they cover in these
articles it's very very interesting one
yeah I really like this article the
particular part I enjoy is like like
what happens when something needs to be
supported by a sari or CRE like do I
just throw it over the
all and be like here you go it's yours
now or is there some kind of oh yeah
exactly or is there some kind of
onboarding process or review or like how
that gets taken in as a company that is
then supported by CRE or SRA yeah I
really like it if you have not read the
SRA book I definitely recommend it this
is kind of like a small tiny chapter of
what could be part of a sorry book it is
not part of it because we're talking
about Siri which is which was not a
thing back then when the SRA book was
written but still super interesting and
really we like life lessons and what we
actually do at Google so you know actual
work experience in there cool so for
another cool thing of the week finally
it took a while coming but we do support
Java right on Google App Engine
yeah it's like a round of applause kind
of moment it's kind of been something
people just a few people have lost for
it it just a couple here they're like no
it's been a long time coming and I'm
very happy to see it there the other
thing I kind of want to feel like it's
buried lead a little bit but we're
talking about basically fully supporting
off-the-shelf frameworks such as spring
boot but also alternative languages like
Kotlin Apache groovy basically anything
you can turn into a war through maven or
a Gradle so that's actually pretty
exciting too I've played a lot with
alternative jvm languages and I like
them a lot so I'm super happy to see
that that support getting baked in yeah
and as my job is to be a little bit of a
troll against the other I will say that
finally Java is getting lambdas for some
definition of lambda anyway also we have
something else which is related to App
Engine we finally have go under date on
App Engine as beta for now but will be
available so it is available we'd go up
now if you use go up you know what it is
G Club will be supported very soon
probably by the time this episode comes
out we'll be supported but maybe take a
couple days March so check it out and it
will be beta for a little bit you can
try it give it a try it should work
because go is backwards compatible but
it's definitely worth trying and filing
any issues if you find any cool and lost
I think but definitely not least is a
wonderfully hilarious things so if
anyone is a fan or a viewer of Silicon
Valley you may you may recognize the not
hot dog application that was made by one
of its characters on the show this is an
article that talks about how this was
built with tensorflow Kerris and react
native yeah like it is an actual thing I
think it's pretty amazing that Silicon
Valley not only they take like actual
people from Silicon Valley to give them
advice but also they use the same
products and they actually develop the
prototypes of the apps they show it's
kind of amazing I really really like it
makes me want to look to watch the show
more ya know it's it's super super cool
and you can see basically everything
they learn about how they could make it
so that you know you could either
recognize that something's a hot dog or
not a hot dog yeah it is and the thing
is that yeah you should you could write
that up if you want to review our huge
fan of Silicon Valley and you want to be
part of the thing yeah I ride the code
and and try it it is actually not that
hard with thenso flow and it should be I
pointed out if you want you can download
the app from either iOS or Android it is
available so if you ever need to know
what's not a hot dog or is a hot dog you
can do that now yeah I really like
there's that there's someone that
actually don't love with the app it took
a picture of his forearm with some
ketchup on top and the abscess it is a
hot dog also a banana with ketchup on
top and he's also hot dog and even an
apple with ketchup on top so apparently
it had been optimized for detecting
ketchup if there's ketchup it's a hot
dog
you know you need you need to maybe
retrain a little bit make sure you
recognize amazing well speaking of deep
learning why don't we go have a chat
with Wendy from Kegel sounds good little
that so I am very very happy to have
today when they can a data scientist
from Kegel
they join Google not that long ago and
we're very happy to welcome you how are
you doing good thanks for inviting me
here thank you for taking the time to
talk a little bit about Kegel and all
the cool things you can do with it
before we start talking about Kegel tell
us a little bit about who you are and
what you do at Google sounds good
I'm
scientists at Kegel I I work with
companies or organizations or research
groups on the machine learning problems
that they want to solve I give an advice
of you know what they should do to their
data and how to form that into a
suitable competition design present them
to our cago community and for people to
solve the problem cool so you mentioned
competition design which bridge is
really well to what keggle does there's
a little bit what what is Cagle and why
do people like it so much
yeah Kengo is a community of data
scientists we're a platform and we're a
community and we have all sorts of
things that surround the community we're
best known for our competitions and most
people know us from the competitions we
also have a very strong product that's
cago kernels that people love to use we
also have a data set platform that
people share open data set on cattle
we're really really close to a million
users that cool so you mentioned sort of
three things there data sets kernels and
competitions
why don't we kind of break those down
actually competitions I think that the
first time I heard about Cagle was when
we did that announcement about the
YouTube contest oh yeah that was a kegel
right yeah that's my project oh nice
that is awesome yeah we use it as a cool
thing of the week I don't know if anyone
from podcast participated but it sounded
like a really good opportunity to try
cool things with data science definitely
so yeah let's let's talk a little bit
about competitions for instance what
what is a competition how does that work
we run all sorts of competitions we're
very small team so the benefit of that
is I get to touch all sorts of projects
I was Mali small when we were acquired I
think we were 15 people
okay that's yeah yeah two data
scientists doing competition design so
there's not really like what kind of
competitions I run everything cool so
like what's an example of a competition
I don't we've mentioned the YouTube one
but so I just launched one this week
it's a million-dollar prize Zillow
competition it's going to be predicting
how
prices that's very exciting everybody
has a lot of ideas about how to improve
their house prediction and you know
zestimate has been a big thing that
people talk about and use a lot and we
want to have a competition for people to
basically just see how hard the problem
is and maybe it's easy and somebody can
solve it better than testimon that'd be
great I was laughing about it because
I'm going through the Coursera course on
machine learning and actually the the
first example ever is how to predict
house prices exactly that is very
interesting that that still goes on even
when you become a professional and you
drink competition still the same problem
because it is kind of with the machine
learning 101 or stats 101 problem that
people want to solve we actually had to
jump through a lot of Hoops in terms of
getting the data and having to license
to release the data so it's not that
easy to get it running but it's very
exciting and we feel like our our
community would love it a lot
nice cool so from like a developer
perspective right I want to go do this
competition what's my process for doing
that and then what's my end result like
how do you determine whether I win or I
lose for a normal capital competition
the Zillo one is kind of a particular
example and I'll go into that later but
for a normal cat girl competition you
download the data from a cattle site or
you don't download the data and use
cattle kernels and just do online
analysis and user browser and everything
is running on the cloud and then you can
basically read through the documentation
that we provide or just have fun and
explore the data itself on the cloud for
the competitions there's always a column
or a property that you are going to
predict and there is always going to be
a metric that calculates how well you're
predicting against the ground truth the
answer and you basically you submit a
bunch of predictions in the CSV file and
we'll give you a score and that score
puts you on the leaderboard and you can
see that there are a lot of people ahead
of you you will want to improve your
score and beat these people in front of
you one thing to notice that to do good
machine learning practice we have a
public and private leader board to
prevent people from overfitting because
when you keep predicting you're going to
over
your model even if you're not trying to
just cheat your model over fit to the
the ground truth so we asked people to
predict a bunch of predictions and only
some of that going to the public
leaderboard that people can get feedback
on and instantly improve their models
but final results are determined from a
private leaderboard where people don't
get the score right away and that's
revealed at the end of a competition so
that's kind of like when you're doing
machine learning you have like the
training set and then the test set and
the validation set like exactly you're
actually exposing the training and the
test but not the validation exactly
you're we give people the training and
the validation is equivalent to the
public leader board and the holdout set
is equivalent to the private
cool and for those people who don't know
what overfitting is what's overfitting
that's when your model is learning
things that it's not supposed to know so
basically if there's particular things
in this data set that is not
representative of the population and
your model basically over fits to the
characteristics of this particular
sample data the way I learned it which I
think it's pretty cool is like imagine
that you have a bunch of points if you
have more parameters than points you can
actually draw a line that goes every
every single one of the points which
doesn't make any sense but goes like has
100% accuracy for exactly that if you
give any other data it will be
completely [ __ ] yeah if you use a
house price prediction example it'll be
like oh like this house is three million
dollars and it has I don't know a door
that's broken and so your model learns
that and then predicts like if you have
a broken door and it's not the case for
all the houses but that's unfortunately
the sample that you pick all right and
to outside of competitions you also host
data sets is that like together or
separate or like what's the relationship
there it is a separate offering and that
part is relatively new on cattle so we
host open data sets on cattle because we
feel like cattle kernels is a very
strong tool for people
and hosting these public datasets lets
people explore these datasets and share
their findings on cattle and also it's
just done you know for a public good
we've all been there to you know look
for our data set and you're just like
randomly searching on the internet and
then you feel like that's available and
can't it's a good place to find all
sorts of datasets and now it's pretty
organic like so far like we published
some and the community would publish
some and a lot of times we were
surprised that the status set is here
it's great
so doesn't mean that I can use it for
whatever I want to do like let's say I'm
learning machine learning right like can
I go and play with any of those datasets
yep correct you can do that it's not
just for machine learning right you
could do anything you could do
exploratory analysis that's not
predicting anything on those data sets
so it's a wide range ranges from you
know how Isis uses Twitter or like
Pokemon statistics data set or like we
found the Bachelorette and the bachelors
on it so yeah so it's pretty cool and
now even if I just want to find like
some example if I want to make a demo to
somebody very quickly I'll go and look
for some new data sets to show off and
these are the data sets that can be
submitted by anybody or yes are their
community powered that's really cool so
we keep mentioning kernels but we should
probably talk about exactly what that is
because I think it's actually super
super cool when I had a look at it so
kakko kernels has I think we launched it
maybe like two years ago you go to calc
calm flash kernels it's very simple it
takes care of basically everything that
a data scientist needs for you know very
quickly run some code to an analyze data
so you click like open a notebook or
open like a code and it pops up in your
browser and you start editing your code
and the data is there depending on you
know if you're in a competition then the
competitions data is all in there if
you're in a data set the data sets data
is all there so as a data scientist
before a lot of times you you go in and
you receive a new data set and you want
to explore it you you if you don't have
a computer
that you have already set up spending
hours and hours of you know installing
packages then you're gonna spend hours
doing that but for this one also our it
uses a docker image and that's community
maintained so most of the packages that
people want to use already in there so
it's pretty convenient it's also a great
place to show off your work and to
benefit from other people's work usually
when you run it it's it already becomes
public so people can see it so if you
want to say you know like I have this
new text data set and I want to see what
other people do with it and then you
read other people's notebook and already
did this amazing analysis and you can be
like oh I have this new idea that they
can extend from then it's just like
github when you where you can fork it
you know you can make a new version what
with that you still don't have to
download any code on your computer it's
just all stays on the cloud and you only
need the browser to do that cool so you
have all of these big data sets and
people can provide data sets then you
also have these analysis like the
kernels where people can provide code
that you run on that data set and all of
these runs on the cloud who pays for
things like do you need to pay for it or
how does this work so right now right
now Kaggle pays for all of that okay of
course because it's a free product we we
we have a limit on people like how long
you can run the code for and there's a
memory limit in the future we definitely
probably after the the integration with
GCP is complete we'll see if there's a
way to let people to customize what they
want to try to run in like for example
there's a lot of neural network stuff
that needs to be run on GPU for it to be
fast right now we don't have that
capability
we know that GCP has it but we need to
enable that and then see where it goes
so that part is kind of an unknown but
so far we have a pretty widely used
interface for in a community that's
using it very actively yeah I love to
actually interview the team again once
you have
finish the migration to GCP and see like
if using GPUs or GPUs and all that stuff
that'd be a very interesting episode
definitely so yeah that's that's a
really great segue into so recently
recently a few weeks months something
like that you were acquired by Google
cloud what does that mean for keggle I
mean you talk a little bit about moving
over to our infrastructure is there
anything else you can discuss the
acquisition definitely is a big change
for our lives we moved over to Google
offices and are using Google computers
we are still operating as an independent
brand we kept our Kago emails we have
our site and we are still mainly focused
on growing the capital community and you
know we want to we won't bring the best
content and best product to our users so
that's sole that still doesn't change we
stole that's still always our goal and
we want to bring the best to our
community the change for cargo and GCP
integration is upcoming and it's
probably not going to be very obvious to
our users because it's gonna be in the
backend right now
the community knows that Kaggle was run
on a sure a lot of code base are based
on c-sharp so that's kind of a big
challenge to move over to GCP and we're
definitely investigating on what could
be done and what needs to be done so
it's not gonna be it's gonna it's gonna
be a slow cast it's not gonna be
anything fast and it's not of course we
the main focus is we want to grow our
community so the integration is second
and we believe that it'll be the best
for our community because of Google's
infrastructure and powerful computer
cool so I guess that since you mentioned
c-sharp nah anchors about so most people
that do machine learning
nowadays they do use Python and some
libraries one of those libraries is
tensorflow
it's tensorflow something that you can
use on top of cargo is that the only
thing you can use I'm assuming not since
you're mentioning c-sharp well how does
that work what libraries gonna use on a
kernel yeah
just a clarification the c-sharp is kind
of what the site is run out so the site
doesn't have can't really say it doesn't
have Python biz you know majority is in
c-sharp there's
I'm hiding everywhere right but our
cattle Colonels what the data scientists
would use and and what I use and our
Python and our so in cago kernels
there's there's no c-sharp obviously so
yeah talking about tensor flow in the
frameworks it's a good question
tensor flow is available on cackle
kernels not because of the acquisition
is just because it's a popular framework
for people to use newton network on and
now a lot of other things it's a great
framework and it's getting a really
great momentum for people especially
that Kharis has always been a community
favorite for deep learning framework and
now Karis has switched to using tensile
flowers back-end so it's becoming more
powerful and that has been a favorite
for cattle
you mentioned terrace what is Charis
Charis is kind of a higher level
framework for using deep learning it's
great that people love to use it because
it's you don't have to worry about a lot
of the details set up you could say I
want to layer this and I want a model of
you know this shape and it's very easy
to use and what's great about it is that
it can connect to different frameworks
on the lower level too so it's very
heavily used by cattle communities and
you'll see a lot of carers usage on cago
kernels and just generally people use it
a lot and I know the curse how do you
how do you how do you write it like if I
want to search it because I would say
c8r are OS curse its kera s cool okay
now Google sorry the author is now at
Google oh nice yeah
so that's the tensorflow integration
cool so on on top of tensile flow then
you can also use all the libraries like
if you want to use actually the know of
any other library other than visionary
but I'm sure there is there are
kaga wants to remain very neutral on
these tools and that you know we want
people to use whatever tools that they
prefer so we don't specify we don't push
you know for people to use anything
because you know people should feel free
to use whatever they want to use and I
mentioned Karis there's also there's
also you know great frameworks like cafe
that people use a lot and these days a
lot of people start to use pi torch
definitely a lot of different frameworks
that people prefer to use and generally
we just love to have a diversity of
different frameworks on our site and I
know our community was concerned when we
got acquired that you know we're gonna
heavily pushed n surf though or stuff
like that and it's definitely not our
position to do that because we feel like
we're just uh we're platform we want
people to use the best tools that suit
their needs and we give content and
people choose their tools and we'll
support them so really it's about just
providing the underlying infrastructure
to them as they need us or like GPUs or
bigger memory sizes or anything else
that I can take exactly I do feel very
excited about tensorflow for my my own
use cago has always been we have these
competition sponsors and they're looking
for a solution and the community would
provide them with a great solution
before over the years it's always been a
kind of a disconnect between the
prototype that the cago community
provides and what they can actually put
in production so a lot of times its
first it's like heavily ensemble which
means just like a lot of different
models are put together averaged and
it's not very production friendly and
I'm hoping that with tensorflow I know
how Google is investing in a lot of
infrastructure on making these things
production ready and hopefully these
would make the transition between the
prototyping and the production work
easier and that would be a great benefit
for our customers and for the community
to because you're doing all these fun
work on capital and then if you don't
have to if it's not another tough
project to put it in production then it
awesome cool so just to go a little bit
over all the things we went through we
went over so Kegel has data sets and
those data sets are allowed for anyone
can contribute new data sets and you can
use them for whatever you want like you
can download them and like train them by
yourself if you want you that's correct
you also have kernels which is like
basically like scripts that you're gonna
be using to model to train some models
Korean again anyone can go and see them
and you can participate into like it
forking them and improving them or
whatever yes in then on top of that you
have competitions yes
can can you also contribute competitions
yeah definitely so we have been working
with this competition is almost coming
to an end that you guys have announced
it it's the YouTube competition anyone
can propose a competition to us and
we'll definitely talk to people you have
to have the data you have to have a
problem in mind a lot of my work is
talking to people and understand what
they want to solve they have an idea and
then they have a data set and a lot of
times the data set really doesn't solve
the problem so I could brainstorm with
them well your data set is about you
know I don't know People's Bank
activities and you want to predict
climate change and it's not really
related but you could probably predict
if this person's gonna go to a bank and
open a checking account you know things
like that we provide that service and
then we we select things that are
helpful and are interesting and our you
know meaningful to our users and
hopefully hopefully gets you know it
lets people to touch data and problems
that they normally don't have the
opportunity to touch and their normal
daily lives and to try new things so
that's very exciting the other thing
that's exciting about I was talking
about the YouTube competition is that
normally in the past for cattle users we
have smaller data sets and smaller
computing power and this one we're using
Google Cloud and
it's a large data set that people
normally don't have access to I think
it's like 7 million videos or something
and yeah I remember there was like 8
million the cotton the contest is
YouTube 8 million
then there's 8 million videos there's 7
million videos yeah which is ok but
because there's 1 million like training
data that one MIT 7 millions is the
training data and I think that 1 million
is the validation you would know it's
your competition I think the story is
actually they release a first version of
the YouTube 8 million and oh that's one
thing that is special about cattle
competitions is that if it's a public
avail available data then people know
the answer to come to the competition
then we can't run that competition if
it's already public can't ask people not
to cheat but what do you mean if they
know the answer so for example if we ask
people to predict like the presidential
election of 2016 oh I see ok yeah doing
things in the past has to be easier
right so they had to release that to
analyze new videos and release these
kind of with Tagil and then hide some of
their labels for us in order to make the
competition fair so that's the 7 million
got it nice well we're gonna running out
of time I am super excited like as I
said I'm learning a little bit of
machine learning and it feels like cago
is the perfect place to keep on her
anymore and play with a bunch of data is
there anything else that you'd like to
mention something that we found where we
might have missed yeah join our Zillow
competition it's a the biggest price
ever it's a very yep it's enough money
for you to buy a house maybe not in San
Francisco join that competition and
we're also very excited that we're gonna
welcome our million user very soon so
yeah so cattle is doing well and we
definitely hope more people with joined
Kaggle
start exploring and learn data signs
with us with a big community so thank
you so much to Wendy can for spending
her time explaining a little bit about
what cargo is and all the cool data sets
that they have the amazing competitions
and how you can make money by being a
data scientist very good experience yeah
it looks like a really great way for
people to sort of get together and
collaboratively work on machine learning
projects using big data which is super
cool yeah Ilana it really feels like
it's the kind of thing that if you're a
student you should definitely try
because you know at worst you're
learning in a path you're making money
so I'd say I'd say go for it and I think
it's time to go for our question of the
week the question of the week I'm going
to ask it because like the answer is I
think you're gonna probably give a bit
better than me but it's okay I want to
do client-side load balancing we cheer
PC and cover nice so if you have a cover
net a service well you get from the
service norma is one IP which is virtual
IP that you send your request there and
it's done there's somehow it gets load
balance it to a bunch of pods that are
behind but the problem is that as long
as you keep one connection with your PC
you will send all of your requests all
the time to the same pod until that pod
pre-start and then you will send it to
someone else but what if I want to
actually see read that load across all
of the pods that are available how do I
do that from the client so yeah this is
this is kind of a fun problem and
something that's been talked about a lot
in GFP I'm sure you can find lots of
threads on it the basic answer for G RPC
is what you often do is what's called
client side load balancing so basically
you feed a series of IP addresses to
your G RPC client then you tell it how
you want a load balance and say like
round-robin right does one than the
other than the other so the fun question
becomes like how do I get all those IP
addresses how do I tell it the four or
five 15 IP addresses and ports that
eight needs to know to connect to and
then can then subsequently send and
distribute those requests across those
IP addresses so inside kubernetes
there's a couple of nice ways of doing
it will link in the show notes to a
github repository that one of our other
teammates write sang started as a Java
example because I know franceska is all
about that all the time exactly we
two different ways so one way is using
DNS service discovery which is a
built-in tool kit that comes with a gr
PC
so last week I want to say or several
weeks ago a comment but now we talked
about headless services and communities
so what those end up being is rather
than having a single DNS entry that does
a load balancer itself like a
server-side load balancer that points
out to all these plugs behind it what it
actually has is a DNS entry but with
multiple a records each with an a record
to point to the IP address of the
various running instances behind it so
basically you can hit that DNS and be
like hey give me all your a records and
that gives you the catalog of all the
plugs behind so you can get access to
all of those running instances and their
their IP addresses and connect to them
so then if I if I'm at the client then I
get a list and I can go over all of the
IP addresses in that list but what if I
have many clients do you have many
clients that's fine you can do that for
every client that ends up connecting
that's totally cool yeah
and what's great is G RPC comes with a
DNS name is over middleware that you can
just drop in that understands oh if you
have multiple records on this DNS record
then I know that I should be round-robin
around though so I should be load
balancing across those given a certain
strategy yeah and on top of that also
kubernetes will rotate the order of the
IPS every single time you get the DNS so
if you get a bunch of different clients
connecting to Salinas
you will actually end up hitting by
default to some kind of round robin at
least some kind of load balancing
automatically on top of the load
balancing that you might want to do
which is pretty cool that is really cool
now there's another way you can also do
it which is kind of neat as well and and
Ray gives us another example fat wherein
you can query the kubernetes api service
discovery so it's got a whole api in
there where it's like hey would you like
to tell me all the IP addresses so
rather than going through dns you can do
it through that way as well so there's a
couple of different ways you can do it
as you need to depending on your wants
and or needs yeah I wrote a little code
doing exactly that using the API the
kubernetes api but rather than querying
the kubernetes api every time what i did
was i had a little side guard that
actually got notifications from
kubernetes api because you can watch
something so you watch the list of APs
and every single time there's a new pod
or a thought of disappears you're
automatically notified
whenever you want to send a request you
already have a list which makes it
faster so yeah lots of really cool ways
to do the same thing really go with the
one that works better for your workflow
absolutely all right well before we
finish up I know you're cute calm right
now but what have you got going on
Francesca so yes I am a cucumber right
now by the time this episode will be out
and we be back to San Francisco
hopefully and right after that I will be
out to go freak on in Denver very
excited about that I'm gonna be running
a couple workshops so it's gonna be
pretty intense looking forward to
meeting all of my dear Gophers from all
around the world what about you
well I'm not going it for a little bit
but in July I will be in New York for
the Google cloud summit I'll be there
presenting with Phoenix one games nice
that sounds really fun what day is it
it is the 18th of July perfect I will
don't be there I'm actually taking that
week off completely so well you enjoyed
New York I will be enjoying some
holidays very nice very nice well Fran
says thank you again for joining me for
yet another episode thank you Mark and
thank you all for listening and we'll
see you all next week
you